i was talking to beck good old glenn
beck uh pretty deeply about this stuff
and kind of what he was telling me
though is unfortunately when we talk a
lot about people like it's gonna be a
revolution we gotta we gotta fight back
you know i i mean i was at the capitol
today and i ran into an officer who i
saw on january 6 and we were talking
about it and i'm not going to get into
much details but you know he got pretty
injured there's a lot going on and
he just kind of was like hey i've
actually been wanting to talk to you and
i don't know how we end up running into
you on the streets here in dc again and
we were talking about and i was just
saying yeah like this is a confusing
time in in our country because we
it's hard to make sense of things uh of
what's going on what our future holds
and that kind of told me i asked him the
same question hey like what does the
future hold for america what does the
future hold for australia what what what
does it hold for people who are saying i
i'm sick of this uh present
tense version of chat but like i'm i'm
sick of this you can't say the word but
i'm sick of this and like what do we do
to to
yeah to overturn this how do we fight
back and you know he gave me something
that's kind of disconcerting but also
bluntly honest he said we're never going
to see a type of revolution like we have
seen in the past because simply put
every one of those revolutions including
the civil war uh the only reason the
tides turned is because a foreign
government that had interest ended up
investing money into a group that ended
up winning for instance in the civil war
there was great interest the french had
in seeing the british empire decline and
so that's why they funded us so heavily
because anybody that could weaken the
grip of the british empire opened up
trade for them and also even he said
even in the civil war which i didn't
know
the money was pretty unilateral from
european countries between the north and
the south because they were really
afraid that if the south ended up
winning that they would be end up being
tariffs and problems with trading with
cotton and different and different trade
deals so they kind of sent money to both
sides and it wasn't until i forgot which
battle it was but there was a turn in
the battle that they took their money
out of the south and gave it to the
north which ended up giving them the
upper hand to win and so if you look at
even american history the fight against
tyranny or the union trying to win back
the country or whatever people think
always involve foreign money and now
with this global economy this global
interest right after wilson sold us out
to the federal reserve and you have this
global banking system where companies
you know are against american
traditional values there's no
corporation or country or banking group
that's going to just come in and fund
let's say a revolution in australia to
fight back it would be a guerrilla fight
probably more like the taliban but even
the taliban has some people say it's
funded by pakistan some people say it's
supported by iran
there's a country that's going to fund a
revolution in america
who china
for the left
yeah true yeah they're gonna they'll
invest in in tons of these programs
they'll they'll place you know uh spies
all over the country and they'll start
putting out woke propaganda which
they're doing which destabilizes the
country it sounds like what's already
happening yeah no no no
i'm talking about i'm talking about what
they're literally doing
i'm not predicting anything china would
do the same thing in australia i mean
they probably are but they probably well
that's exactly it so daniel andrews
actually the premier of uh victoria
because we don't have governors we have
premiers um he at one point well
actually i believe he's taken ccp money
but at one point you should find the
clip if you guys are interested there's
a clip of basically um a victorian
police station i believe playing some
like communist anthem chinese communist
anthem or something
rather than the australian national
anthem or perhaps or maybe maybe i'm
getting my wires crossed and they're
flying the chinese flag i can't remember
but the point is that they have so many
little creepy ties to the ccp that it's
like oh that's why everyone's in
freaking perpetual lockdown
to go back to what you said there's
there's a different reason i think
you're not going to see a revolution
like any of these past civil wars or
revolutions and it's that we're in a new
generation of warfare why should anyone
need kinetic warfare when you can simply
post a series of tweets and convince
someone of something and then they'll be
on your side is that why they say
communism was never tried correctly
someone told me that that meant that
they were always using initial violence
to purge rather than social pressure for
allegiance and that the way that they're
kind of using this is to bring people
into state control before they have to
do an
eventual purge imagine if i said to you
no one's ever tasted unicorn no no
person has has ever really tasted true
unicorn you'd be like unicorns don't
exist hey you're starting to get it
there is no real communism this idea of
this like everyone owns everything
utopia makes literally no sense it's
it's just like saying unicorn so when
they say real comedy has never been
tried you're like yeah no one's ever
ridden a unicorn i get it
you're not going to it's never going to
happen and the only way to do it is to
take some kind of fake horn and jam it
onto the face of a horse and bolt it
down or something and the horse is all
screaming and you're like it's a unicorn
i swear
that's basically what they put alex
jones there sticking sticking fingers in
cow's mouth boating stuff your horse is
gone
there's a tweet you would laugh at this
because you're i always think of like
your little face you're just like like
that weird face
face yeah but somebody somebody wrote it
was like a meme and somebody wrote they
were like yeah i can't wait till
communism um is you know finally comes
in because i i can't wait to figure out
what i'm gonna do with my farm and then
it just kept zooming in on my and then
it was like
my farm
somebody tweeted what are you gonna do
once communism is finally achieved yes
and then someone responded probably take
some new classes hang out in the town
teach people how to grow vegetables on
my farm spend some time with the family
and then someone responded with your
farm yeah yeah it's like horrifying
these people don't understand just to
see that response from someone about
what they're going to get to do
so it's like you know
funny back to that just just just look
at what the north koreans are allowed to
do all right that's what you'll be
allowed to do starve to death yeah you
have at least three options of haircuts
yeah at least they can get haircuts in
north korea because in a lot of cities
in the united states we weren't allowed
to get those that's crazy because you
would hear that two years ago lydia i
know this too because you're like pretty
like free spirited person and so you
would go to a point where you would hear
oh they're like
litigating what kind of haircut you can
get me you can be prosecuted or fined
for going against a haircut that's crazy
to live in a society where they would
the law would get into getting haircuts
and then all of a sudden i remember i
had to literally do a drug deal
basically in in
california by like paying a guy cash
going in through this back door to get
my hair haircut and it was it was like
the windows were covered and i was like
i thought it was like a human
trafficking situation and it was just so
i can get scissors to you know trim my
hair and i'm going we went quickly from
that seeming dystopian to that is they
have more freedom with their hair than
we do
oh yeah honestly just just to this thing
about this just made me laugh because
jack pus i just want to say this because
it actually made me laugh and i think
other people will find it funny too jack
pasobic responded to that thing you're
talking about and he posted this picture
that said oh you thought communism would
support you so you could write bad
poetry and sound cloud rap all day
instead of laboring in the fields haha
please face the walls oh yeah it's just
like
what i like to say to people i usually
say i'm talking about ubi but it applies
here too um
uh how many people do you guys know play
guitar
a couple a handful a handful yes um and
how many of them are really bad at it
uh a handful a handful of them yeah yeah
and
and and will those people
be like if if they had the option not to
work they'd be like i'm going to be a
musician
yeah i will probably
yeah so yeah
guitarists do we need
not none yes
so there's two problems here one we
already have too many people who want to
make careers out of non-productive
fields though i love the arts and think
people should try to make art there is
an issue where in our society over the
past several decades or generations
they've been like instead of inventing
things why don't you try and be a famous
singer because i guess people make a lot
of money doing that so we prioritize
that now we have a lack of trades people
and we need people to you know fix our
toilets and build our houses and there's
much there's very few people to do it
and there's very few truckers but i tell
you this these people who want communism
many of them are these bad guitar
players who are like i hate working at
starbucks if we were communist i'd play
guitar all day it's like dude you'd be
breaking rocks all day yeah exactly you
think they're gonna no they're gonna be
alike to each according to his needs or
what was it what is it from each
according to their means to each
according to their needs
yeah bro you don't have very much means
or needs why would they give you
anything or let you do anything your
means are you got arms and a rock needs
to break we're not going to ask you to
solve any equations here buddy into the
fields you go you know what's funny
though is speaking of like people
actually being dark yeah it
it's kind of weird because as much as
we're going to probably um rage against
australia rage against the machine in
australia in this episode what's what's
kind of funny is australia's actually
got down pat quite well that whole
making people useful thing because
tradesmen or we call them tradies in
australia there's tons of them because
people don't waste their time trying to
be bad musicians it's a very
american-esque thing in my opinion
because there's a lot of entitlement in
this country much as i love living here
and much as i love americans there's so
many great qualities of americans
there's a butt ton of entitlement that i
find exceedingly irritating that aussies
simply don't have aussies are much more
humble much more willing to take
criticism in some capacity than
americans would be and and there are
these things where again when we talk
about these like communist ideals and
things that's why like elijah was saying
before aussies are actually quite
resistant to it it's more the fact that
they trust the government too much which
is why it plays out the way that it does
whereas americans weirdly enough are you
know i think that there's probably a
bigger proportion of them that are like
oh communism could work because then i
can play my my guitar all day and they
swore again tim i'm sorry yeah i was it
nearly came out of my mouth no no no no
but stopped and i stopped got it i
stopped after after the show and started
screaming all the profanities she
couldn't get out shaking this she's
shaking this is what she does she's a
women's sabotage they subvert but also
it's true
we have to inform tick-tock that is not
true and it's a joke yeah tick-tock
actually took down one of our videos
really yeah it's like a joke like this
[Laughter]
this is where people don't understand
with australia and being orderly is
people someone could tell them call me
racist for saying this it's just called
living in los angeles and the reality is
one of the things that struck me as the
most odd it wasn't the spiders and it
wasn't the little death creatures that
kill you on vacation in the water
it was
i remember seeing how and this is going
to offend some people but understand
where i'm coming from here
that being a tradie wasn't seen as being
blue color is in america meaning when
you're going down the 405 or the 605
freeway or something in california
there's a very distinct look for the
majority of people working for caltrans
or on the streets of most of them are
hispanic a lot of them are overweight
unhealthy there's always a joke right
that how many people does it take to uh
to to dig a hole in california on the
road one to hold the shovel a bunch to
stand around looking at that nine nine
because that's just what it is this
inefficient expensive mess of people who
not all people are but just this this
government waste project i was shocked
and they're usually late 30s mid 30s
late 30s when i went to australia
i know you know australia it is these
young men 1920 cut chad looking
jaw dudes who are just masculine
just dressed pretty well not they're so
gross good good haircuts like what we
would think of being like a navy seal or
something this is what it looked like
and they're just efficient they're
moving i saw a project get done like one
week on the street
and i remember like going in even into
the state-sponsored you know alcohol
whatever whatever those things are
there's like big stores where you can
only get alcohol at uh because you can't
get in the supermarket the bottle shop
yeah but the big ones what's that one
the bottle oh the bottle shop oh you
like dan murphy but like the line there
was like a line of people that were all
dressed like tradies buying their beer
getting ready for the night like you
could tell they had this regimented
lifestyle and i remember talking to to
my wife and she was like yeah like being
tradie is not looked down upon here like
oh you didn't go to college you became a
tradie which is actually a detriment to
our country because that's the point is
that we've created a system of work
where college colleges you know matters
i think you just made a tweet about this
that about what that you know that why
would you oh
imagine hating your kids so much you
send them to college yeah but that's my
point but they're being traded the
civilization isn't set in this tears
like that kind of work is still seen as
like you're building the country you are
you are building the the the framework
and a good job there is good for the
nation the nations are very united in
that way and so it makes sense that they
would fight against
like this there's a there's a bunch of
tall ripped chiseled
white men yes who are building the
country and want absolute government
control and spying on all of your stuff
it's weird isn't it this is this is
nazis
i think australian men are objectively
the best well i think australians are as
a general rule very very so like in
australia chris hemsworth is ugly no
he's just standard he's like he's like
below he's below average they export him
out to the us like
now you know what she thinks about us
christian
like what is it
i just like i look at some of the
boyfriends that i had in australia and i
like
contrary to popular belief i'm not and
elijah can back this up and i think you
can back this up now too lid um
basically like i'm not a shallow woman
like i like brains i want you to be
smart i'm not like other girls i'm not
like other girls i'm quirky okay but i
like smart people i want to be
challenged i want to you know someone
interesting who can talk
we have a picture of uh one of sydney's
ex-boyfriends right here do we it's a
chris hemsworth yeah no it's that meme
guy
you know the black and white photo of
the guy who's like chin is like oh my
goodness i'm just kidding it's not a
real person i do love i do love a good
chin no but on a serious note like i
look i think back to some of these
boyfriends i'm like oh my god they're
actually like very handsome people like
unironically just like normally handsome
people because aussies are attractive i
don't know i don't know other people
back me up here i think horses are hot
it sounds like they're in bread is it
true to a point if they're not allowing
the boat people in we don't
what is happening part of why we're so
beautiful
is it true that the tradesmen are super
hot too like tradies are so hot and they
wear these like little little um they
wear their little short shorts but i
love oh my gosh and they wear their
little boots which look really cute with
their little like you know high vis
stuff and i'm like oh god the
temperature is rising in here
australia is missing um a storyteller of
people that want to be storytellers and
the america is overrun with people that
want to be storytelling we don't want
your storytellers so you can keep them
right like it's an important role in
society a job even you could say as an
actor you know they're highly paid
musicians just the shaman that would
tell the tribe but we don't need 100
million storytellers you know you just
need really good ones at the top and
it's such a a small group of like you
know people want it it's like this this
exclusive group that people all want to
do and so they're sitting around lazily
waiting to get their chance or to get
their viral video that now they get to
be this ian i think you you
fundamentally don't understand
industry in the united states like the
overwhelming majority of movies and
music are small businesses
i
i don't know you said you were an actor
before but i don't understand how you're
not aware of the fact that like most
films are small films no one ever sees
because they'll get like a thousand
viewers like i know tons of people in
chicago who would do uh short films and
they would it would be at a small
theater in chicago to a thousand people
over a weekend and that was the end of
the film maybe and those are jobs people
are getting paid hundreds of dollars to
do and they would have budgets of like
five to ten thousand dollars and they
would film for a day or two right
because if someone wanted to be a
storyteller they would just start
telling stories on the internet they
would make a short film a
low budget film instead people maybe
they want the fame they want to be the
storyteller they want they want everyone
to listen but a lot of those people
story to a dark closet you know what's
the point of the story really a lot of
those people won't make it because
they're chasing the wrong thing what
makes you
famous is your passion for what you're
doing and i'll give you an example i i
i was once doing this voter registration
thing at a death cab for cutie con
concert and they're like you know this
indie band i don't really know what
they're been doing this past decade or
whatever but i saw the band hanging out
backstage and i asked them i was like
you have any advice for making it music
and uh the guitarist said just keep
playing music because one of the things
that happens is everyone around you just
quits they eventually give up they quit
they stop playing and then eventually
you look around and realize you're the
only one left and you've got this big
back catalog of all the music you've
produced and a lot of people are
familiar with it now because you know
everyone else is gone and i was like oh
wow i'm paraphrasing because it was the
gist of the conversation and it's like
if you stay true to what you believe in
and you're playing music and you're
doing what you love eventually you're
getting better at it every day you're
producing a lot of it more and more
people start to see it and the people
who don't really want it are like i just
want to be famous and they start
quitting and then eventually it's like
five ten years later and people are like
oh yeah i've seen that band before
they're really good and they're sharing
your stuff every single day someone's
playing your song someone's hearing it
so that that's true for like most things
you know it's funny though because i
think that that actually applies to the
job that i guess we all do in a sense
because i feel like there's a lot of
people out there who look at this and
think i could do that and really i mean
anybody who could if you're you know if
you're uh well spoken if you're well
read if you will take the time to look
into politics all that sort of fun stuff
and i think what bothers me a little bit
and sorry to derail this but you just i
just think this is a you know decent
caveat to what you're saying um there's
a lot of people who get into it wanting
to be famous which i think i think
that's the worst reason to start doing
political commentary to be completely
frank with you because it's not easy you
really have to be on top of it and all
credit to you actually tim and i'm not
blowing smoke up your butt but you're on
top of this stuff it's like you you like
live and breathe in and just like you're
like a little swamp creature that's
surrounded by all your news articles you
know like yeah i have like a nest of
like exactly newspapers that i gather
and you just
she says
is standard normal and she called you a
swamp creature wow
your audience is going to be like never
bring this girl back ever again put her
in the bin no but seriously
it does bother me that how people are
like oh i want to be famous i'm going to
be a political commentator and it's like
well oh take a run like a red hot crack
at it take a run at it fine but i don't
i don't know about that well they do i
know plenty of people who who try like
it's like the stupidest idea you know
that's what i think too it's it's not
easy you get a lot of hate mail i think
everyone's the dumbest idea but then
this is wanting to be a political
commentator to be famous
but around trump time it became cool
yeah because that's the whole point is
that you got i'm not going to call
people out by name here but it became
not just like a grift thing but it was
like for the first time they politics
right is hollywood for ugly people and
so for the for the first time now you
have a movie star i mean we had reagan
but you have this sort of television
personality it's got this big
personality about fame and kind of out
there and it's all about the shows and
and going to the uh convention centers
and going to all the speeches and so
this whole sub tier you know these
non-profits develop and all these people
because of social media could put maga
in their name could do anything for
trump and it was seen as like counter
culture and cool and because of
algorithms you could get this following
and so you could be anything with maga
and you could be cool and so the problem
with that is is that it became about
celebrity and so our side became very
much that you actually could be cool and
could make money and could get ahead
without having any bright ideas or any
ability to make it but everybody hates
you
right and i mean everybody i just mean
like you're you you put yourself in a
position where a lot of people will
despise you not in the algorithm though
because the algorithms used to work that
you would think that everyone liked you
because you're like oh yeah
that's why i'm saying it's stupid you
know for the people who didn't see what
was happening that's why you have some
you have so many of these youtubers who
are like on the right and all of a
sudden they're like actually i'm on the
woof and now they're just like saying
stupid establishment talking points that
don't make sense to try and pretend to
not be conservative because they realize
like hey wait a minute
all of the big money big tech big
hollywood yeah they're banning people
who have these opinions and they're
funding people who have the other
opinions and all of a sudden they found
themselves on the other side of those
opinions because look you want to be
famous on the internet and you're
willing to put the work in i don't know
play fortnite or minecraft or whatever
the kids are playing make more money too
yeah it's it's absurd
you go to twitch and you look at like
the
100 000 concurrent viewers viewers that
someone's getting from you know playing
some some video game and talking about
drama stuff and and sure you still get
haters you will
but you can see there's a lot of
celebrities there's a lot of actors and
actresses and musicians who make all the
money in the world
if you're willing to put the work in and
everybody just is like oh they're pretty
cool people like cannell reeves who
hates keanu reeves
like nobody i want to know the names
because i'm coming for you give me the
link right everybody loves the guy
it's like he's like he's a cool dude he
minds his own business and he doesn't
even hover hands
yeah he doesn't want to offend anybody
yeah he hoverheads women he knows so
that he knows the game so much but he
knows what he's in but like but but what
you were saying was a lot of people do
want to do this and that's the problem
because it's not their passion so not
bring anything new to the table that's
why they fizz out because eventually
people get tired of you i think people
look at it objectively and they go that
looks easy i can do that not realizing
how much time effort energy goes into it
not just even on like just for example i
said to my mum recently because she's
just dying of just sadness in melbourne
at the moment just under lockdown and
everything and she's having my whole
family's having a hard time especially
especially my mom and so i said to her
because i wanted to give her something
to do i was like hey i could make videos
a lot quicker if i had someone helping
me do all the research because i'm a
one-man band i do everything myself so i
say would you mind helping me my mom is
a very very intelligent woman i thought
that might be something that would
occupy her brain while she's you know
dying in bloody lockdown so she says yes
of course and so she starts helping me a
little bit with with researching and
then she says sydney i actually didn't
realize how
difficult this is you know how you have
to find qualitative sources how you have
to read just so much information even
just to get to the the kernel of what
you needed to go into this part of the
video and this that and the other and i
said yeah it's not like you just wake up
and go i made a video and then just jot
something down and jump before i'm
hanging oh i'm sydney no it's like it's
this whole in-depth thing so what you
find is that and i'm sure that you guys
have seen this too and i'm sure you can
think of use guys i can't speak english
i'm sure you guys have seen this too and
you can probably think of people off the
top of your head as well who've done
this but they come onto the scene they
go this is easy i can do it too which is
again fine take a running red hot crack
at it the more people who can support
right-wing ideology or you know moderate
ideology whatever fine i'm happy with
that and then they fizzle out because i
find it's not easy it's not easy and
that's why tech talkers make me so cross
you know i turn the sound off and
they're just doing this i've also seen
people
say like that's i can do that and then
they do it and they win and that was
phil defranco he in the very beginning i
was making youtube videos and he started
and he was like didn't know what he was
doing but he watched me and was like
this guy's not good at what he's doing i
can do that better and then he did and
then
he said that he saw people doing it
poorly and he knew he could do better i
think he was talking about me and maybe
other people too
that is the move too is it is that it's
like well most of the stuff is bad i
could at least do better i was trash no
research i was getting stoned i would
make videos not a big deal whenever i
felt like it it wasn't
sometimes
no shirts yeah no cows it was terrifying
you know the secret secret is though it
was raw you know there's exactly there's
one big secret to success outside of
everything we've ever talked about they
say perseverance right but there's
actually one big secret and it's a good
memory
so
you know i i suggest people do memory
games memory workouts because if you
have quick recall that's how you become
witty that's how you're able to connect
the dots and and find points that other
people haven't considered so if you see
a news story where they're like you know
the cow jumps over the fence and you're
like hey wait three weeks ago they built
that fence to stop cows from jumping
over the fence and the cow was able to
just jump over it anyway yo that was a
waste of money then you have hey guys
they wasted you know 100 bucks on
building this fence because remember
last week if you can't if you have a
terrible memory and a lot of people
don't have you know good recall then and
you've got to have a bunch of memories
at once so you can remember a bunch of
things at the same time and then they
all form like a giant over memory that
you can pick different you can see like
contingencies and
you know angles
you got to be able to recall context a
lot of you know a lot of videos are
people will just edit them you know
they'll they'll be talking and they'll
stop and they'll look at their notes and
they'll start talking again and that's i
think what most people do some people
can't even do that because i've i've
tried you know giving people advice and
they're like man i don't know how to do
this and i just i just talk i don't know
i don't have any notes like i have like
the news stories and i'll read them
that's better that's again like i know i
feel bad for saying it but it's your
your scrum you're you're swampy creature
with all your little articles around you
yeah i've got all the i i take i take
physical newspapers and i i rub them all
over them
into a nest and then i roll on the
ground on my side and i scrape the dirt
over my body like a chicken yeah
people wonder if this is like a cult or
whatever and i'll tell you the first
time the first time that i came in here
they literally did take make me pick my
favorite news article they printed it
out
they ground no they grounded it down
literally into like a pookie pipe and
they made me smoke okay this is this is
it's absurd
the only thing that actually happened
when elijah first showed up is that we
set the table and we chanted google
gobble
over and over again
now when they all stand in a line you
can actually the branding spells
something that's very good clever yeah
yeah nobody actually lives there's like
three people who actually live in this
house yeah you drive up you know it's
funny when when uh people ask they're
like oh what's tim's like i'm like a
compound isn't it
but would you call it a compound if it
was this exact same thing but like in
the middle of chicago i would not i
would i would call that um that would
that's object sadness object sadness if
you were in chicago there's a cow
outside i don't know what that's there's
no that's okay oh i would get a towel
though that'd be cool there's chickens
outside exactly
you guys got cats too don't you cats one
cat maybe maybe some goats
i heard goats being tossed around not
literally tossed around
yeah little goats the pygmy goats they
jump on the backs of things and yeah i
want to get a talib
oh my goodness i was walking total this
is so not politically oriented but i was
on a walk with my new puppy i just got a
puppy he's the cutest thing in the world
and i'm like waddling along on this like
walking track and i look up to the side
and there's a bloody pig someone has a
bloody pig in their backyard
bloody what do they
was it like a pot-bellied pig it was
just this like cute little little piggy
i don't know it was it was just pink was
it doing pig stuff
yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time